[Music]
shaquille o'neal's accomplishments both
on and off the court have turned him
into a massive brand but now another
long time passion is taking center stage
you say in this book you're 71 325
pounds size 22 shoe so you said i know a
thing or two about eating
what do you know
i know that dr lucille o'neill my mother
even though we didn't have a lot
she made us feel like we had a lot
i'm a big guy i would always ask for
seconds and third and she'd be like man
i hope when you get older you have a
good job
good job check and now shaq is sharing
some of the meals he grew up loving at
home with a twist
in his first cookbook shaq's
family-style championship recipes for
feeding family and friends it includes
80 comfort foods with lots of flavor
you open the book and you say everybody
should sort of pump yourself up you said
you should look in the mirror let the
crowd call your name
check and say you should pump yourself
up what is your pump yourself up speech
that you give yourself
don't burn the house down
don't burn the house down
and pay attention to what i'm doing
because like in the kitchen like you
really have to pay attention like
sometimes when when i'm in the kitchen
even though i'm 50 years old these guys
treat me like i'm a little kid hey man
turn around you're gonna burn the
restaurant down shaq has known his
executive chefs matthew silverman and
matthew piekarski for over 20 years
they teamed up to draft recipes that
even the self-proclaimed world's largest
11 year old can follow tell us about the
grilled cheese shack
it's grilled cheese
cheese
what is this
pork it is pork there's some
pickled onions great question girl
we tried those barbecued pulled pork
grilled cheese sandwiches yum
bacon-wrapped meatloaf glazed with grape
jelly
you like grape jelly they said
but we could not miss one of shaq's
favorites
cheddar crust chicken pot pie and a
comfort food that put me out of my
comfort zone there's just something
about the texture of brits that bothers
me
carolina barbecue shrimp and buttery
cheese grits
these are good in the book there's like
five or six ingredients and it's a it's
a great cajun spice say i came over on a
saturday night what would we be eating
what else is going on basketball game i
like a basketball how about a nice
rom-com you like rom-coms
and we have some champagne yeah like
welcome gail hold on is this a date or
are we just friends we're just we're
just friends okay we're different okay
so champagne should it be a date i don't
know
you're too young for me miss girl yeah
that's true i'm too young for you okay
what's what's the main entree that
you're serving big chicken uh-huh
broccoli
maybe some macaroni you know i have to
say guys i don't notice a lot of
vegetables up here
what is your thinking with that shack
i don't eat a lot of vegetables go you
don't no
should you eat more vegetables i don't
have to i'm i'm
pretty strong and pretty fit shaq's
cookbook is the latest on the list of
projects that he's pursued since hanging
up his jersey 11 years ago you do seem
to have made the transition from
basketball your basketball life
to your next chapter i mean
so many players are not able to
successfully make the transition
did you have a game plan
i know a question you're asking me and
the answer is i had to
when i was coming up my parents did a
great job of
showing me negative stories
six percent of nba players lose
everything when they're done
educate yourself
financial literacy don't do this
come home with the big chains and the
diamonds take it back save your money
save your money save your money
and so when you look at your own
children you have six children what was
your message to them about money and
what it meant
and what they
deserved or were entitled to well now
that they're older and they get mad when
i say this i always tell them we're not
rich i'm rich that's just to
you know keep them well grounded
we teach them about respect
teach them about honor i teach them
about following their dreams
what gives you the greatest joy these
days my family my mother
when i talk to people they say why are
you always happy i said because i limit
my stress
i have what's known as one hand stress
what does that mean the things i only
worry about is my mother
my children
my businesses myself i don't even get
the five if it's not one of these four
doesn't bother me yeah do you think
about your legacy
you're still young i know what my legacy
is already oh okay share a juvenile
delinquent that listened to his parents
and followed all his dreams period and
shaquille o'neal
still
dreams big this is the thing about you
shaq you have a business career djing
which you clearly love i've seen you you
clearly loved to do music
music and sports are the only thing that
can bring people together no matter
what's going on it also gives me that
adrenaline boost that i've been missing
for the last 11 years you missed the
game oh i just missed the
hour
dj diesel
what would be the song you'd play for me
i slow the music down and i'll be like
this song is dedicated to the lovely
gayle king did you ever know that you
were my hero
what would be a fun song you'd play for
me
i want to feel the heat
one of my favorite parts is you said
it's not over till dessert
it's not over until banana pudding is
served
you and i have to disagree though
because i believe banana pudding should
be warm you believe banana pudding
should be
let's go cold you believe it should be
cold
see
you hear that that's the banana pudding
police
[Laughter]
that right there is the banana pudding
police i don't believe you said that
banana pudding cold america banana
pudding warm america